l équipe de guignol
bonsoir
les clients la grande rue alors je vous
demande de vous arrêter
alors bruno gaccio on vous présente plus
et c'est bien dommage
dans cette émission tous les quinze
jours donc on va arrêter de vous
présenter à chaque fois seulement tous
les quinze jours et je sais pas lionel
dutemple alors vous on se présente à
lionel dutemple j'ai 36 ans sera air
france
ouais 13 vous êtes pilote d'avion non
chef avion c'est moi qui dirige les a
vus à la carte
ça plane pour vous quoi exactement très
bien ahmed hamidi vous vous présentez
soir à neda midi 33 ans
j'aime les parents je suis pour l'entrée
de la turquie en europe
bruno gaccio semaine vous étiez là pour
le guignol et le magistrat vous revenez
aujourd'hui pour l'année des guignols
le dvd en deux semaines vous avez fait
comme une émission de télé bois no 2 aïe
c'est tout ouais j'ai fait ardisson et
pascale clark en aparté parce que c'est
une très très bonne émission qui est pas
fatigante à faire en même temps un vous
avez vendu combien de livres
la tentation c'est de répondre je suis
pas libre est en ce moment et qu'il est
bon les lignes j'ai entendu parler de
cette bouquin vendu à peu près à peu
près vous avez pris combien de petits
déjeuners un hôtel costes pour parler
avec des journalistes
j'ai pas pris tous les petits déjeuners
des fois je suis partie au milieu de la
nuit d'accord en deux semaines vous avez
fait l'amour combien de fois 0
l'amour l'amour
j'ai fait l'amour 0 froid non basi non
pas dire j'en ai paniqué un bac es
d'accord je vous ai manqué ah oui
d'ici là
alors les dvd l'année des guignols un
jean-pierre ça peut tout faire
donc c'est l'utilisation de jean pierre
raffarin sur la couverture du dvd c'est
une contrebasse ouais vous l'utilisez
pour faire des phares des phares à vente
de chevaux
bien que chirac qui s'en tire comme
premier ministre finalement il peut
servir à plein d'autres trucs ce mec-là
vous diriez quoi pour qu'on l'achète le
dvd achetés eux sinon on est viré
ouais et comme ça je pourrais faire
l'amour au moins deux fois par semaine
alors on va voir à quoi ça ressemble à
ce que voulaient bien regarder votre
caméra en dix ans tous les trois
ensemble
magnéto serge 3,4 magnéto serge bien